[Music]
well a new report shows las vegas homes
remain
uh at a record high the median price for
a single family home sold in january
take a look right here
345 thousand dollars now this
is up by 13 now moving on over to the
next
sale which is the condos and town homes
which i'm told are also up with an
average one selling in january
for 119 193 000 which
is also up by 10 percent
let me see here sorry about that by
about 10 percent
uh basically since january of 2020. now
take a look here on your screen las
vegas realtors say
supply and demand is driving up those
numbers there's a shortage of homes
available for sale mortgage interest
rates
are historically low leading to more
sales and record prices
however there's a chance that the
housing supply will see more inventory
in the coming months new listings
increase substantially
from december to january it's a great
time in history to own a home
um when you look at the the interest
rates i keep saying this over and over
again because they're just
so incredibly low i've never seen
anything like that at least in my
lifetime
when i bought my first house i paid 10
10 and a half percent interest on a va
loan
back in 1990 now we're sitting at you
know 2.675 you know 2.75 for an interest
rate on the home
it's incredible and something
interesting to note a report by fitch
and
analysts estimated that among the 20
largest metro areas in the country
las vegas had the most overvalued
housing market